the reason that we are here at
Disneyland Star Wars Galaxies edge
because it officially opens tomorrow but
last night trust me when I tell you bye
- was bumping this thing is the Star
Wars legends help Disney CEO Bob Iger
opened the parks largest land ever a 14
acre Jedi paradise the main attraction
is Millennium Falcon smugglers run so
naturally I had to get into the cockpit
for this kid who snuck into the movie
for the first time this is a dream come
true this is a fantasy moment come with
me and let's live out this fantasy
riders get to pick a roll either pilot
gunner or engineer you know I decided to
be a pilot
[Applause]
get up ya know come on you guys joke
how do I break here we go hold on oh
[Applause]
that was okay that was crazy
Kelsey was my co-pilot she did okay but
that is one of the great attractions I
have ever written it Chewbacca's
screaming the bumps the up and down it's
bananas let's go back listen to me
that was amazing by the way coming later
this year there's a second attraction
star wars rise of the resistance they
say it's even more ambitious than the
Millennium Falcon come on now and by the
way Disney's Hollywood studio in Florida
will open its galaxy's edge on August 29
the Borg is so excited about that
just like I want to do it Kevin
sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]